[音楽]
今日は
あなたあなたあなたあなたと私のストーリーをお話しに来ました
よく考えながら聴いてください
考えるのを止めないで聞いてください
さて
この数字
一町995おく
一戦162万円7776
この数字なの素地だかわかりますか
あなたは10分後約10分をこの数字
何の数字だか分かっています
そしてこの数字
数え切れない数字私4や a のない数字かなあって思ったかもしれません
だけれどもこの数字よりにより多い数字をよーく考えられるようになっています
考えるのを止めずに聴いてください
時間
空間
そして
パワー
力エネルギー
について
いろいろな観点からお話をさせていただきます
あなたは生き物ですあなたもあなたもあなたも生き物ですね
そして
私も生き物です
これ私の小さい頃です
さて
あなたたち皆さん
オイル何食べましたか
3-1
じゃあ何グラムぐらい食べましたか
200g
そうですね僕らは食べ物を食べて
体にエネルギーを入れて
それを消費ながら活動しています
僕らは物質ですなので200グラム
食べると200グラム体重が増えますお寿司美味しそうですね
a
いろいろな
その中に食べ物中にいろいろな栄養成分があってそれだから
体に
物質としてものを入れて活動することができています
一方で
運動をしたり
トイレに行ったり
100g 出すと
100g 体重が減ります
そういう循環が僕らの体をつくっているのです
さて
1歩踏み込んで
小さな世界に行ってみましょう
僕らの人間の体
の元素の割合はこのような割合になっています
水素
そして酸素
たウンソちすと
リン硫黄
そして骨を作るカルシウムなターン
また
血液を
動かすのにひきしな山荘
取り込むのエキスなヘモグロビンのもととなる
鉄
その他いろいろな多量な元素でできています
この中の色々な元素を使っているわけです
ちょっとでもそれが欠けていてもバランスが悪くなっても僕らの体は機能しません
一方でこの減損によって構築された
うれしい
分子が僕らのからダムでも動いています
そして分子の中に
僕らの生命の設計図である
その設計図の基本言語である dna というものがあります
dena には4種類あります
dna という言語で書かれた
小
あなたの身体の部品を書いてある症があります
その言語で書かれた賞
それが
遺伝子と言われるものです
遺伝子はタンパク質
を行動していますそしてあなたの部品の
作り方を書いてあります
例えるならば
あなた
お父さんお母さんそれぞれから
23巻ずつ
染色体という百科事典
プレゼントされています
その百科事典の中に dna という言語で
遺伝子の中に遺伝子と優勝の中にたんぱく質の
情報が書かれているのです
おとうさんとおかあさんからプレゼントされたそれぞれ23本ずつ合計46本
ゲノムと言います
そして
エネルギーをつかさどる
また小さな小事典のような
ミトコンドリアゲノムというものをおかあさんからプレゼントされています
たまに
この
染色体を
この百科事典を一貫多くプレゼントされていったり
一家少なく
持っている方もいますがそれもギフトです
そして僕らの設計図ができているわけです
僕らはその設計図を元に身体にいろいろなものを取り込んで
物質も取り込んで色々な出会いがあって僕らを構築しているわけです
今度は時間的に一歩引いて見てみましょう
人類の
あいみ
ホモサピエンスわれわれホモサピエンスですね
私たち人類は
約25万年前
アメリカの大事で誕生したと言われています
これは
まあ研究者だとかあとはディーエヌエーの解析で明らかにされてきたものです
そして
約16万年前
アフリカを出て
いろいろな国に散らばっていきました
これもいろいろな骨の化石だとかそういったものから明らかにされています
そして
それぞれの国々いろいろなところで文化を形成してきました
いろいろなものを食べたり色々な暮らしぶりをしたり
そして
まあいろいろな言語
駆使してお話をしたりしてきたわけです
さて
あなたを一つのカードとしましょう僕青い官とします
可能だと考えてください
あなたという
ゲノム
プレゼントしてくれたのはあなたの両親二人ですね
そう僕は兄弟が3人いるので
それぞれ両親からプレゼントされた半分ずつプレゼントされた物を
3つ
それぞれの兄弟に分け与えられています
若干その半分ずつなどで組み合わせが違います
そうやって多様性があります
さて容姿について考えてみましょう
両親は
その両親からすなわちおじいちゃんとおばあちゃんから
ゲノムをプレゼントされていますね
2世代さかのぼると
何人の
たたからプレゼントされたことになりますか
4人そうですねおじいちゃんとおばあちゃん
ゲノムをプレゼントしてくれたおじいちゃんとおばあちゃんは4人です
そう
お父さんとお母さん1+1 day 2
2世代さかのぼるとにかけるにで4です
1世代を約25年だとすると
100年で何世代ですか
道
そういった100年で1世代を4年25年だとすると
100ある25は
4ですねはい
えっ
4世代になります
そうにかけるにかけるにかける
ひいおじいちゃん
曾おじいちゃんで初
聞い日おじいちゃんで
いいんですね
はいにかけるにかけるにかけるに16位の4場です
じゃあもっと考えてみてください
ふえっ
千年では
なんせ台ですかもう答え出ちゃってるけどどうぞ
だぞ
そうです
40世代ですじゃあにの四十条いくつですか
にを40回掛けます
こんな数になります
みんな40条1兆959億円
1戦162万円
7776人です
理論上1戦年前にあなたにゲノムをプレゼントしてくれた人はこの人数になります
でも一戦年前
あなた
そんな数はいませんでしたね
実際は
まあ700万人ぐらいだという風に
ただ当時な
文献などから
推測されています
じゃあこの2時の違いは何でしょうか
よく考えてみてください
考えるのを止めないでください
なんでしょうね
ちなみに青年前
この現地の物語のような世界だったみたいです
種明かしをしますと
あなたの両親おじいちゃんおばあちゃんにも兄弟がいてその
さらに先祖にも兄弟が入って
その先祖同士がつながっているわけです
あなたの隣同士の人300年前で先祖が繋がってたり
5006年前で線路が繋がってたりするわけです
日本人であればそう
アジア人であっても
かなりの確率でつながっています
この中にいる
5人は
誰かしら親戚なわけですね
うっ
さて人類が
その一方歩み始めた25万年前では
合計
何人の
木の6を分け与えてくれた
戦後がいることになるでしょう
25回る25結構簡単ですね
にの一万城にになります
でも実際
そんな人数はもちろん地球上に存在しえません
実際は10万人ちょっとやったと言われています
その10万人が
それぞれの一方を歩み始めて
世界中に広がっていきましたあ
そして僕たちが立っています
最後に僕
あなたあなたあなたあなた
あなたはお父さんの清酒とお母さんの卵子が
出会うことで生まれてきました
その出会う確率は
約2時奥を
降りませんもっともっと
少ない確率です
宝くじが
何回も1頭で当たるような確率です
そんなような確率をお父さんもお母さんも
そしておじいちゃんもおばあちゃんも積み重ねてきました
この図なんか
この形状なんか似てませんか
かな形状
そう
わかりますか
トーナメント表ですつまり
僕は
その
確率に勝ち残ったチャンピオンあなたもチャンピオンなんです
僕も皆さんもチャンピオンです
そして
ここに次世代のチャンピオンがいます
どうぞ皆さん考えることを止めずにそのつながり
皆さんのつながりをよーく深く考えてください
ありがとうございます
[拍手]